as to the question of role models in the
Middle East I'm not I'm far from an
expert on the Middle East but I do know
that in the u.s. having role models is
extremely important when I went to
college the school I went to a very few
women on the faculty there were very few
women in some of the classes I took and
it was a struggle to kind of figure out
how to how to do research how to be a
person with a certain kind of role when
there weren't women there and I'm sure
the same kind of example will hold for
other groups if you're you look at a
type of work and you see no one there
who's like you not only to make it
harder for you to get a job but it makes
it harder for you to see yourself in
that position so I think bringing
together people who have similar
interests and encouraging people to know
other people who are doing that kind of
work or that kind of researcher that
kind of thinking but who are they can
identify with can make a huge difference
in young people and people moving up in
their careers
you